WHICH THE RULES -- YOU VOTE.
THAT IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> AND JOINING ME NOW TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IS FORMER DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR FROM MINNESOTA AND HOST
OF THE AL FRANKEN PODCAST,
FRANKEN HIMSELF AND FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
PENNSYLVANIA, CHARLIE DENT.
SENATOR, LET ME START WITH YOU
FIRST.
THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO SOUND
THE ALARM ABOUT POTENTIAL
VIOLENCE WITHOUT FURTHER
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY, AND YET,
74 MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR
TRUMP IN THE LAST ELECTION.
YOU SAW THAT, WE WATCHED THAT
LIVE SHOT A FEW MINUTES AGO FROM
KRISTIN HOLMES, THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE AT THIS RALLY TO SEE
DONALD TRUMP SPEAK DESPITE
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
HOW DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN
HANDLED THINGS THE OTHER NIGHT
IN TRYING TO THREAD THE NEEDLE,
IN TRYING TO REACH OUT TO ALL
AMERICANS?
>> I THINK WHAT HE SAID WAS
ENTIRELY PROPER, ABOUT 70% OF
REPUBLICAN, SELF-IDENTIFIED
REPUBLICAN VOTERS THINK THAT THE
ELECTION WAS RIGGED, AND THAT'S
INSANE.
IT'S JUST BEEN PROVEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT THERE'S NOTHING
THERE AND THAT'S VERY DANGEROUS.
THIS IS -- AND LOOK, THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
CALLED THE ENCOURAGEMENT, THE
RIOT AT THE CAPITOL LEGITIMATE
POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
THIS IS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS TO
SAY THAT THAT -- THAT VIOLENCE
IS LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE.
HE HAS EVERY -- IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT HE SAY THIS, AND I DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE REPUBLICANS WHO
AGREE WITH HIM, AND THERE ARE
REPUBLICANS AND I THINK CHARLIE
IS ONE OF THEM WHO UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S KIND OF INSANE TO SAY
THIS ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
IF YOU HAVE ALL THESE MAGA
REPUBLICANS, SOME OF WHOM, A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF WHOM SAY
THAT VIOLENCE MAY BE NECESSARY,
THAT'S VERY SCARY AND THAT
SHOULD -- THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
JUST THE RIGHT BUT THE DUTY TO
CALL THAT OUT.
>> AND CONGRESSMAN, WHAT ABOUT
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE PRESIDENT'S
MESSAGE, AND HOW WORRIED ARE
REPUBLICANS IN PENNSYLVANIA
RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
SENATE RACE AND ALSO THE RACE
FOR GOVERNOR FEATURING DOUG
MASTRIANO, WHO IS AN ELECTION
DENIER?
I MEAN, HE IS ONE OF THOSE
REPUBLICANS AL FRANKEN JUST
MENTIONED.
HE IS SOMEBODY WHO DOES NOT
BELIEVE THE PREVIOUS ELECTION
RESULTS.
>> WELL, LET ME START WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S COMMENTS.
I THINK, LOOK, A LOT OF WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID IS
ACCURATE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
DOMINATED BY DONALD TRUMP AND
THE MAGA WING, THEIR RULING.
MY PROBLEM WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
SPEECH WAS I DIDN'T APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS ABOUT SEMIFASCISTS.
I DON'T LIKE WHEN REPUBLICANS
REFER TO DEMOCRATS AS SOCIALISTS
OR COMMUNISTS OR SEMI-SOCIALISTS
OR SEMI-COMMUNISTS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S SMART.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S VERY GOOD
POLITICS, IT'S DIVISIVE EVEN
THOUGH HIS COMMENT ABOUT AN
ELEMENT IN THE PARTY THAT IS
QUITE DANGEROUS.
WITH RESPECT TO DOUG MASTRIANO,
DONALD TRUMP INFURIATED MUCH OF
THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP IN THE
REPUBLICAN COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA BY ENDORSING
MASTRIANO.
THEY DID NOT WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN.
ALSO, MANY OF THEM WERE BACKING
DAVE McCORMICK FOR THE SENATE
SEAT, AND HE WENT WITH MEHMET
OZ, SO TRUMP HAS REALLY -- HE'S
REALLY CROSSED SWORDS WITH A LOT
OF FOLKS IN THE STATE WHO CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE, SO THAT HAS
BEEN A BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM.
IT'S EVEN MORE INTERESTING, I
THINK THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT OZ AND MASTRIANO HAVE
APPEARED TOGETHER.
I KNOW THAT OZ HAS NOT BEEN -- I
THINK HE'S BEEN AVOIDING
MASTRIANO TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE BECAUSE MASTRIANO, THIS
IS A MAN WHO WAS EJECTED, THROWN
OUT OF THE STATE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN HAIR
--
HARRISBURG.
YOU REALLY HAVE TO WORK AT IT TO
GET THROWN OUT OF THERE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S EVER HAPPENED
BEFORE.
THIS MAN IS VERY EXTREME ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS IN THE
STATE LIKE MYSELF WHO HAVE
ALREADY ENDORSED JOSH SHAPIRO,
SITTING ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
GOVERNOR BECAUSE JOSH IS AT
LEAST A MAINSTREAM INDIVIDUAL
AND A DECENT HUMAN BEING, AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BACKING HIM,
BUT SO I THINK THERE'S A REAL
PROBLEM AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
ANYTHING DONALD TRUMP DENIED IS
GOING TO CORRECT THE ISSUES OR
THE PROBLEMS THAT MASTRIANO HAS.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
MOVE BACK TO THE CENTER OR TRY
TO APPEAL TO MORE MODERATE
VOTERS.
IN FACT, HE'S DOUBLED DOWN ON
WHERE HE IS, SO THIS IS -- I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE POINT OF THIS
IS.
GOING INTO WILKES-BARRE AN AREA
TRUMP HAD DONE VERY WELL.
OBAMA WON THAT COUNTY, AND OF
COURSE DONALD TRUMP WON IT IN
'16.
SO KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON THIS
COUNTY.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS THE BEST
PLACE TO DO THIS RALLY.
>> AND AL, I MEAN, A FEDERAL
JUDGE UNSEALED AN INVENTORY OF
THE HIGHLY SENSITIVE GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS THAT TRUMP HAD AT
MAR-A-LAGO, AND IT REVEALED THAT
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE MIXED
IN WITH CLOTHES, GIFTS, MAGAZINE
CLIPPINGS.
THERE ARE ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT
EMPTY FOLDERS THAT WERE FOUND,
48 OF THEM MARKED CLASSIFIED, 42
MARKED RETURN TO STAFF,
SECRETARY, MILITARY, WE DON'T
KNOW IF ANYTHING IS MISSING, BUT
THE OFFICIAL LINE FROM THE TRUMP
TEAM HAS BEEN TO DOWN PLAY
EVERYTHING AND COMPARED TO
OVERDUE LIBRARY BOOKS, I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S THE LINE TRUMP
WILL USE TONIGHT.
I SUSPECT HE IS GOING TO TRY TO
DEFEND ALL OF THIS IN HIS OWN
TRUMPIAN WAY.
>> I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
WRAPPING MY BRAIN AROUND THIS
WHOLE THING.
IT'S SO BAD, AND IF YOU'VE SEEN
BILL BARR AND KARL ROVE, ANYONE
WHO'S FAMILIAR WITH CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS KNOWS HOW UNBELIEVABLY
AWFUL THIS IS AND HOW LAME
EVERYTHING THAT TRUMP HAS BEEN
SAYING ABOUT THIS AND HIS TEAM,
THIS IS CRAZY TIME, AND IT'S
VERY DANGEROUS, VERY FRICKEN
DANGEROUS, AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THESE DOCUMENTS HAVE GONE.
WE DON'T KNOW -- THESE EMPTY
FOLDERS, 40 SOME EMPTY FOLDERS.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, CLASSIFIED.
THIS IS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
>> AND CHARLIE, EVEN TRUMP'S OWN
ATTORNEY GENERAL, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR IS
NOT BUYING THIS, AND LET'S
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> IF, IN FACT, HE SORT OF STOOD
OVER SCORES OF BOXES, NOT REALLY
KNOWING WHAT WAS IN THEM AND
SAYS I HEREBY DECLASSIFIED
EVERYTHING IN HERE, THAT WOULD
BE SUCH AN ABUSE THAT -- AND
SHOW SUCH RECKLESSNESS THAT IT'S
ALMOST WORSE THAN TAKING THE
DOCUMENTS.
>> YEAH, CHARLIE, IS IT A GOOD
IDEA GIVEN THIS INFORMATION IS
PROGRESSING THE WAY IT IS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
TO SHARE A STAGE WITH DONALD
TRUMP BEFORE THE MIDTERMS?
>> OF COURSE I NEVER SHARED A
STAGE -- NO, I NEVER SHARED A
STAGE WITH HIM WHEN HE RAN THE
FIRST TIME EITHER, I WOULDN'T
GET ANYWHERE NEAR HIM.
I THINK BILL BARR IS RIGHT.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE HERE,
I MEAN, HE WAS TOTALLY CARELESS,
RECKLESS, AND AS AL SAID,
DANGEROUS WITH THE WAY HE HAS
HANDLED CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
HELL, HE ABSCONDED WITH IT IS
WHAT HE DID, AND AL FRANKEN AND
I BOTH KNOW WE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
TO SIT IN CLASSIFIED BRIEFINGS,
AND THEY WOULD HAND US PAPER.
WE WOULD READ THE PAPER AND WE
WOULD GIVE IT BACK.
ANY OF US WOULD HAVE NEVER
WALKED OUT WITH THOSE DOCUMENTS
AND CHOSE NOT TO RETURN THEM, OF
COURSE THE G-MAN'S GOING TO SHOW
UP AT OUR HOUSE AND THEY'RE
GOING TAKE THEM BACK.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS.
THIS IS A PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
CASE, AND YOU KNOW, I URGED MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE TIME OF THE
SEARCH OF TRUMP'S HOME TO BE
VERY MEASURED, BE VERY CAREFUL
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A TIME TO
START DEFENDING A MAN WHO HAS
DONE SOMETHING THAT ANY MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, I'M SURE THEY'D BE
PROSECUTED FOR IT, AND TRUMP IS
DANGEROUS, AND AS BARR SAID, THE
FACT THAT -- HOW COULD HE
DECLASSIFY THIS STUFF?
THERE'S A PROCESS TO DO THIS.
HE DIDN'T DO ANY OF IT, AND WE
ALL KNOW IT, A